Guten morgen tim.
Linus wasser auch schon auf seiner hygiene demo.
Komm tim ich glaube über die sind jetzt echt alle witze gemacht worden lass mal einfach sendung machen.
Aux
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertfünfundvierzig vom elften mai zwanzig zwanzig immer noch.
Drin im jahr was sind wir jetzt eigentlich gerade so war immer noch voll im look down der nicht mehr so aus ne.
Wir sind ja jetzt im down oder in jedem bundesland irgendwas anderes,
also ich habe den überblick tatsächlich jetzt auch verloren was jetzt hier noch noch gilt und was nicht vor allem ist er als in jedem bundesland anders und zu anderen zeiten ich würde ehrlich gesagt sagen,
ja so wir sind gerade am anfang vom ende des lockt.
Am anfang vom ende des lokführers.
Oder anfang vom ende der ersten welle.
Die wahrheit ist wir wissen alle überhaupt nicht wo wir sind und es wird jetzt sehr spannend sein zu sehen wie sich das ganze in den nächsten vierzehn tagen entwickelt klar es gibt immer so diese bilder von leuten die im park zusammenhängen pipapo und sich zu eng irgendwo reindrängelt et cetera pp.
Kann natürlich alles ganz böse enden aber ob das nun wirklich so ist wissen wir nicht weil es sind halt am ende auch alles nur so ja anekdotischen,
evidenz ist ja nicht dass das gut ist das überhaupt nicht gut und ich persönlich muss sagen ich werde mich auch noch weiterhin,
er nicht im look down halten aber ich habe keine pläne jetzt groß mich und das volk zu mischen bahn zu fahren in kaufhäusern rumzulaufen ich will,
maximal einmal die woche irgendwo schnell fünf minuten durch den supermarkt huschen und das war's dann auch.
Ja also ich man ich,
also ich glaube was was jetzt hier wahrgenommen wurde von der politik ist dass diese maßnahmen
der letzten wochen eben tatsächlich eine absolute ausnahmesituation waren die sich so auch nicht aufrecht erhalten lässt.
Da musste jetzt irgendetwas passieren und.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen dass es bei der ein oder anderen person dann auch einen zynismus gab zu sagen na ja okay dann lockern war halt ich meine was haben wir denn zu verlieren allenfalls wird es halt wieder schlimm dann versteht die leute wenigstens worum es gibt,
ja dass das dass das quasi so ein bisschen die die die idee ist ne,
der hat irgendwie sehr schön armin laschet will die bevölkerung bald dann auch wieder von der pflicht befreien sich nach dem kacken die hände zu waschen das wäre auch ein,
und witziger eingriff.
Ja
Aber ich kann mir das tatsächlich vorstellen dass das auch durchaus so eine komponente hat jetzt zu sagen ok ihr wollt dann macht dann guckt mal,
wir haben diese grenze diese unverhältnismäßig hohe grenze mit diesen fünfzig neuen fiktion pro hunderttausend pro woche und dann gucken wir mal wer die als erstes schafft die ersten vier haben es die ersten vier landkreise haben schon
und ich also ich weiß es ja selber nicht kann ja also es gibt ja tatsächlich einfach.
Wie bei jeder anderen entscheidung die bisher in diesem bereich getroffen wurde zu wenig daten und zu wenig wissen um vorher zu wissen wie das jetzt ausgehen wird.
Ja das ist alles an presidentin.
Die erste wirkung ist dieses er geht hoch ja also das war zu erwarten frage ist wie hoch und dann werden wir es eben sehen.
Ja gut ob es jetzt wirklich hochgeht dass das wissen wir noch nicht weil man hat in den zahlen halt immer diese wochen schwankungen drin die sind schwierig zu prognostizieren
das ist jetzt eh alles etwas flacher abgeht ist klar andererseits sind wir als ordentlich
gibt ja auch leute die sagen so ja wir haben hier die maßnahmen eingeleitet da hatten wir tausend infizierte und jetzt haben wir wieder tausend infizierte pro tag und jetzt soll es auf einmal alles wieder aufhören so ist ja nicht sondern man hat ja mittlerweile bewusstseins wandel man hat immer noch,
viele dinge sind verboten wir haben keinen
keine großveranstaltung wir haben keine bars kneipen die geöffnet sind et cetera pp die liste ist ja eigentlich noch ziemlich lang was alles nicht geht
und was auch probleme mit sich bringt am ende ist es durchgehend ein experiment und ich kam mir zumindest vorstellen dass,
uns jetzt auf so einem minimal freiheitsrat sport freiheit finde ich an der stelle ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen schwierig ab so ein auf so einem minimalen modus einigen
indem wir die sache jetzt erstmal weiter betreiben während wir wahrscheinlich erschreckt auf andere länder schauen werden wie sie es dort,
entwickelt dass wenn ohnehin die großen nachrichten der nächsten wochen.
Ja was soll das ja alles eine lüge die scheiße die krankenhäuser leer da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu.
Ach gott.
Wir hatten wir hatten ein bisschen feedback dass wir mal behandeln möchten das erste feedback lese ich mal vor dann kannst du darauf antworten das ist von.
Julian tim.
Mich würde interessieren woher linus die vier tage infektiöse täte hat das robert-koch-institut geht von acht tagen nach symptom beginn aus sie beziehen sich auf eine studie in nature
bei der bis acht tage nach symptom beginn repräsentationsfähigkeit virus nachgewiesen wurde diese erkenntnisse sind außerdem noch sehr vorläufig es kann sich auch noch gut zeigen dass menschen länger
oder kürzer infektiös sind dazu kann ich ja ganz kurz antworten ich habe.
Meine diese vier im zweifelsfall bei trosten gehört zu haben und dass sich das dann vier tage nach.
Nachdem im schnitt vier tage nach der positiven testung bezogen hat.
Das glaube ich war meine quelle ich lasse mich aber auch super gerne sofort hier auf acht tage korrigieren weil das mein argument nämlich kein.
Abbruch tun würde dass die phase der effektivität enorm kurz ist jetzt geht's weiter mit dem mit dem kommentar.
Kurz kurz man merkel noch von mir dazu also was vielleicht auch noch mitgebracht hat also vier tage ist ja sie typische,
größenordnung für eine generation der weiterverbreitung wie es in den modellen gerechnet wird das kann sich hier auch noch mit reingeschlichen haben wann genau jetzt dieser symptom beginn ist oder so dass,
max oder so sein.
Es kann sehr gut sein dass ich mich da dass ich dann die tage durcheinander gebracht habe und wie gesagt es macht keinen unterschied für mein argument,
weiter geht's mit dem kommentar ich finde es ehrlich gesagt albern wenn jemand der frisch nachgewiesen kuvert neunzehn positiv ist festgenommen würde und die polizei nicht wissen dürfte dass der mensch möglicherweise infektiös ist,
das dient ja nicht nur dem schutz der beamten sondern auch dem anderer festgenommen
werden übrigens nicht alle festgenommen die mit der polizei zu tun haben also gibt noch mehr menschen die das betrifft,
auch das kurzer kommentar von mir ich habe gehört dass einige leute schon mal begegnung mit der polizei überstanden haben ohne festgenommen zu werden.
Den einwand dass die polizei sicher sowieso immer schützen sollte.
Ist in meinen augen eher realitätsfern weder klinikpersonal läuft den ganzen tag in voller schutz,
rüstung rum die wird ja nicht zum schutz zum spaß mini-anna genannt noch habe ich mitbekommen dass die polizei das tut es macht im alltag schon ein unterschied ob jemand verdachtsfall positiv bekannt ist oder nicht.
Das gibt auch empfehlungen für einsatzkräfte heraus um solche personen zu erkennen und sich dann gegebenenfalls schützen zu können ende des kommentars tim,
was sagst du.
Also erstmal muss ich sagen ich weiß ja nicht wo unser kommentator so wohnt ja aber ich wohne in berlin.
Und wenn ich hier irgendwo polizisten sehe.
Dann hat er alles am start dicke fette montur helm gummi knüppel wumme volles programm handschuhe,
dicke stiefel und so weiter also zu überhaupt den polizisten wären nicht immer irgendwie geschützt,
entspricht nicht meiner realitätsferner so aber hier geht es ja eigentlich um virus so und das ding ist wir haben jetzt gerade pandemien dürfte sich bei der polizei auch rumgesprochen haben es kann einfach,
jeder jeder kann infektiös sein man sieht es den leuten nicht an und die information dass jemand das ist.
Sollte dann nicht dazu führen dass man irgendwie anders vorgeht sondern man muss jetzt generell
natürlich mit mundschutz arbeiten muss generell schauen ist jetzt hier unmittelbarer kontakt unbedingt erforderlich klar kann ja dann sein weil hygiene demo läuft sozusagen aus dem bruder
aber ich weiß auch gar nicht ob die für oder gegen hygiene demonstrieren so ja.
Da fällt mir noch ein schöner effekt wenn du weißt du da hier jede demo auftritt als polizist die leute haben sich garantiert nicht testen lassen ne.
Also da hast du ja dann auch wirklich ein durchaus ein aspekt der ungewissheit in in deinem job.
Aber ich denke dass der kernpunkt der hier bleibt ist ja dieses virus ist ja nun mal deshalb gefährlich und.
In unseren zeiten gerade deshalb so schwierig unter kontrolle zu bekommen weil.
Die infektion vor dem symptom beginnt schon gegeben ist was quasi diese schleichende geheime weiterverbreiten mit sich führt.
Weiterhin die menschen die dann schon geprüft sind haben im zweifelsfall schon symptome sind seit einiger zeit infektiös und sind dann auch bald wieder nicht mehr infektiös.
Jetzt gibt es also unglaublich wenige menschen auf dieser in diesem land die infekt die,
positiv getestet sind es gibt mehr menschen die infektiös sind und es gibt in diesem land relativ wenig menschen die irgendwie mit der polizei in kontakt kommen,
in diesem zeitraum noch dazu personen die als infektiös getestet.
Die nachgewiesenermaßen infektiös sind werden ja mindestens in quarantäne geschickt wenn nicht im krankenhaus.
Irgendwo festgehalten also die wahrscheinlichkeit dass die polizistinnen und polizisten in den genuss dieser regelung kommen indem sie sagen,
schwein gehabt der war auf der liste der weiß ich nicht hundert infizierten personen in.
Diesem kreis und ich hätte da jetzt hin gemusst.
Und jetzt weiß ich dass das dass das jetzt jetzt jetzt bin ich vorgewarnt und werde da vorsichtig hingehen dass dieser fall eintritt ist enorm unwahrscheinlich.
Während es ungleich wahrscheinlicher ist dass du an eine person gerätst die infektiös.
Ist das nicht weiß und da draußen rumrennt ja noch dazu kommen ja so faktoren wie.
Dass ich den größeren teil dieser menschheit trotz aller trotz allem zweifel zutraue.
Sie wenn sie eine korona infektion haben sich an die quarantäne halten und andere menschen waren und selber schutzkleidung tragen mit anderen worten die sitzen jetzt zuhause die polizei kommt und dann sagen die halten sie bitte abstand ich habe korona.
Und sollten die das aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht tun,
ja so ich mache jetzt hier eine ich mache mit dir jetzt eine hygiene demo ja dann wird die polizei ganz andere schutz möglichkeiten in anspruch nehmen müssen.
Also ich denke dass der der fall einfach oder die wahrscheinlichkeit eine unglaublich.
Schmale theoretisch herbeigeführt ist während da draußen in wirklichkeit eine ganz andere realität herrscht und da deswegen denke ich auch dass es
du gerade sagst tim enorm notwendig ist das polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamte eben mit schutzmasken und sonstigen und möglichst wenig kontakt,
ihre arbeit nachgehen können.
Vor allem was jetzt die diskutierte datenweitergabe betrifft die ja an sich schon mal problematisch ist weil es handelt sich hier einfach um gesundheitsdaten und die sind nun mal auch
aus gutem grund besonders geschützt da muss man sich dann halt auch einfach fragen wie ist es denn hier mit der verhältnismäßigkeit der mittel,
denn jede maßnahme die beschlossen wird muss eben auch verhältnismäßig sein und,
deine rechnung ist absolut richtig ja also erstmal die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man genau auf jemanden trifft ist schon mal relativ gering aber die dunkelziffer die derzeit diskutiert wird also von der man.
Nicht genau weiß wie sie ist aber man weiß dass es sie gibt und dass sie mindestens irgendwo so im faktor also im,
im niedrigsten geschätzten fall liegt sie bei faktor vier im höchsten geschätzten fall liegt sie bei faktor zwanzig derzeit ja sagen wir mal zehn ist also zehn,
leute die infektiös sind kommen auf einen bekannten fall derzeit in deutschland und deswegen ist halt einfach diese ganze maßnahme unsinn und bringt,
nichts im schlimmsten fall erzeugt sie nämlich genau das gegenteil nämlich diese gewissheit so a die person
ist ja nicht infektiös weil steht ja hier nicht auf meiner excel-liste ja geil,
hilft ja halt in dem moment überhaupt nichts und fährst im zweifelsfall deine persönliche sicherung runter und das hilft dann halt in dem moment nix.
Wie würdest du das sehen tim.
Oder wahrscheinlich ist es auch wäre das jetzt der fall ich sitze corona positiv zuhause oder auch nicht zuhause habe ich ja eh schon in dem moment ein gesetzes bruch begangen und,
oder oder eine ich weiß ja doch im zweifelsfall irgendein verstoß gegen irgendwas das infektionsschutz gesetzes.
Wenn du meinst wenn du jetzt in karatekeller bist.
Genau ich ich bin positiv getestet ich gehe jetzt irgendwie nach draußen auf einer demo werde dort verhaftet.
Und sage niemandem von meinem corona positiven status und.
Stecke bei der gelegenheit halt noch ein paar ordnungshüter und ein paar andere hygiene demonstranten an ich schätze das würde für mich nicht ganz so gut ausgehen auch juristisch.
Ja und medizinisch auch also.
Ok
Also wie man es dreht und wendet das ganze bewegte sich ja im kontext der fragestellung was ist jetzt hier mit daten und
polizei und es ist einfach mal meiner meinung nach hat eine überhasteten maßnahme die wenig bringt und von daher ist es halt auch unsinn weil nicht verhältnismäßig.
Gut dann kommen wir zum nächsten kommentar von river den kannst du ja gerne vorlesen.
In letzter zeit vermisse ich eine sachlich differenzierte betrachtung der äußerung
anderer auch linus gibt nur seine meinung in seinem podcast wieder auch trosten hat nur seine meinung zur ab der studie geäußert,
wo also ist das problem wenn andere dies ebenfalls tun das bestreben viro logen epidemiologische vergleichen oder präferieren zu müssen befremdet.
Willst du da schon einsteigen oder soll ich das ganze ende lesen.
Kannst du noch ganz viele lesen.
Denn ausschlaggebend ist mit welchem schwerpunkt welche informationen vermittelt werden ob diese information korrekt sind und ob sie vom gegenüber verstanden werden man kann sich übrigens beide anhören anlesen und eine menge dabei lernen,
person am tag,
hingegen überzeugen nicht egal ob das ziel ein virus loge oder fatz redakteur ist dessen name bei tante wikipedia nachgeschlagen werden kann und gleich,
oder schreibt
oder sollte man darüber nachdenken welche der veröffentlichung von dinos ihn dazu befähigen psychologische ratschläge für ein lok down zu geben die zuletzt gehäuften unsachliche weiten in linus ausführungen enttäuschen und sind schließlich grund dafür dass sie mich vorerst aus dem hörerpreis,
verabschiede linus welche was erlaube linus was befähigt dich eigentlich psychologische ratschläge für einen look down zu geben linus.
Ja also man muss natürlich also es ist relativ klar also physiologische ratschläge zu depressionen prävention zu geben dafür braucht man noch nicht mal ein diplom in psychologie,
ich habe aber eins also das wäre der teil den ich dazu sagen kann aber der das andere,
das große problem was hier river scheint nicht ganz verstanden zu haben es geht nicht um meinungen.
Sondern es geht um argumente und wie sich diese argumente mit fakten untermauern lassen ja es gibt irgendwie einen wilden raum der meinungen die menschen haben und es gibt da draußen auch wenn einige immer wieder daran zweifeln
einen großen teil dessen dem was man faktisch nennen kann ja was also fakten sind und es gibt dann möglichkeiten sich diesen fakten irgendwie zu nähren das sind dann zum beispiel studien
wer also nicht den unterschied zwischen der meinung und einem fakt und einem argument.
Kennt dem wird die welt sehr schnell zu kopf steigen.
Beispiel hier christian trosten wenn christian trosten über contact tracing redet dann tut er dies als,
virolent mit etwas ahnung in epidemiologische betont aber selber sogar dass er kein videolog ist und
zitiert dann eine science studie die also in einem der renommiertesten wissenschaftlichen journals die die menschheit so aktuell hat veröffentlicht wurde zum thema contact racing und sagt aha
hier dieses modell macht auf mich betrachtet mit meiner expertise groben sinn das kann funktionieren und kann ein signifikanten effekt bringen ab,
enormer enorm hoher verbreitung von sechzig prozent in der bevölkerung das ist also quasi der ausgangspunkt.
Dann komme ich verstehe was dieses contact tracing machen soll.
Und steuere meine meinung dazu bei oder meine expertise würde ich in dem bereich sagen wie man das pferd
und minimal invasiv machen kann zum beispiel kein ps und keine funkzelle abfrage kryptografisch sichere tokens und sonstiges ja das ist dann quasi der bereich in dem ich expertise habe.
Die epidemiologische wirkung habe ich aber nie
beurteilt sondern immer nur erklärt was andere dazu sagen es gibt aber natürlich auch für laien nachvollziehbar relativ einfache rechnung wie wenn man sagt fünfzig prozent der menschen haben eine app dann bedeutet das,
wenn die person eins.
Infiziert ist gibt es fünfzig prozent wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie die app hat oder nicht und für alle ihre kontakte gibt es diese wahrscheinlichkeit auch womit man dann also nur noch bei fünfundzwanzig prozent,
learning wäre bei fünfzig prozent verbreitung auch das haben wir hier x mal,
beurteilt vor allem habe ich hier immer wieder betont
und das ist noch nicht mal der bereich meiner expertise aber eben auch kein bereich einer meinung dass fünfundzwanzig prozent der infektionsweg vorgänge quasi instant zurückverfolgen zu können,
oder der potentiellen infektionsbad weil es nicht unbedingt heißt dass ein kontakt auch eine infektion ist dass das,
zwar für die einzelperson ein relativ schwaches ergebnis ist auf der ebene der bevölkerung aber trotzdem ein spürbarer und messbares.
Und wir haben hier nie ein so einfaches argument gebracht wie wir wenn das nicht alle haben kann das ja gar nicht gehen weil es gibt ja auch,
irgendwie beispiele wo das nicht funktioniert,
und jetzt geht es hier um die präferenz wird die präferenz bestimmter menschen unterstellt ich vermute dass ich das darauf bezieht dass ich
die sachen die hier trosten sagt deshalb interessant finde und belastbar finde weil er sich auf studien bezieht und es einen anderen podcaster gibt der ein epidemiologische ist ohne nennenswerte veröffentlichungen
der vor allem auch in seinem podcast sich nicht auf veröffentlichung anderer bezieht also droste podcast.
Feiner mann.
Spricht ab und zu mal über seine eigene forschung würdigt aber den größten teil dieses podcast die forschung anderer forscherin um die ganze welt die er mit seiner expertise beurteilen kann,
wiederum sitzt im lehnstuhl und philosophiert über die pandemien,
da ist muss ich tatsächlich sagen da ist die faktenbasiert hier besser wenn tim mit.
Pavel irgendwie und ein paar sprints und ein paar,
gefütterten models an der sache sitzt weil das da wenigstens eine datenbasis gibt für die behauptungen und pavel da eben auch insbesondere andere,
anerkennt und zitiert all das macht die sache nicht der sitzt da einfach und behauptet dinge die regelmäßig den stand der forschung außer acht lassen oder ihm sogar widersprechen und benennt keine,
fakten oder datenbasis für seine behauptungen daran sieht man nämlich man ist genau nicht qualifiziert qualifiziert weil man irgendwer ist,
sondern wenn man ein klares untermauerten argument bringt.
Und gerade zu kontakt tracing haben wir glaube ich kenne ich keinen podcast und.
Kaum eine schriftliche veröffentlichung die das thema in dieser tiefe und so ausgewogen behandelt hat insbesondere geht das ja hier so weit.
Dass ich mich mit tim zanken weil er technischer argumente die.
Nicht im sinne unserer politischen präferenz sind nicht aus in meinen augen nicht ausreichend würdigt
ja während tim dann sagt tue ich wohl du betrachtest das nicht ja das heißt wir argumentieren sogar mit wir nehmen spezifisch die argumente
anderer in unseren augen weniger geeigneter ansätze auf und spiegeln die hier wieder obwohl sie noch nicht einmal unsere eigenen sind.
Ähnlich übrigens wie es auch der christian trosten mit einigen studien macht wo er eben sagt hier das hätte ich anders gerechnet oder sonstiges und das ist das lieber,
oder liebe river auf das du achten musst dass nämlich es nicht um meinungen geht es geht hier wirklich am ende um fakten.
Und die fakten sind aber so kompliziert und die zusammenhänge sind so komplex dass wir gerade im bereich einer penny nicht alles ergründen können es gibt also das universum der fakt.
Und aus dem universum der fakten werden stichproben genommen ja und diese stichproben werden dann interpretiert und gerade studien und das ist das,
wirklich deswegen finde ich wissenschaft besonders cool insbesondere naturwissenschaft in sage ich mal sehr viel komplexeren bereichen was weiß ich sei es jetzt hier ein neues virus sei es zum beispiel auch psychologie weil.
Auch studien und experimente wenn sie schlecht designs sind keine eindeutigen schlüsse zulassen,
und das ist die hohe kunst der wissenschaft quasi die schlüsse die aus der fakten.
Oder die aus der datenbasis getroffen werden darauf abzuknüpfen ob es alternative erklärung dafür gibt ja und wer auf dem niveau sich mit einem thema auseinandersetzt.
Das ist eine ernstzunehmende auseinandersetzung und wer das nicht tut oder zu schon am einfachen test scheitert die fakten.
Die umstößlich eindeutigen fakten verstanden zu haben diese person disqualifiziert sich dann zumindest,
ob es aus weitere von der teilnahme an der diskussion und genau das ist der fall in denen du hast es hier ja angesprochen veröffentlichung der
fast wäre übrigens danke für den hinweis dass sich die klarnamen hinter dem pseudonym offenbar in der wikipedia finden kann.
Ja dann gab es noch ein jahr technischen.
Kommentar die reichweite wird immer von wem ist der kommentar kommentar ist von februar,
die reichweite von logbuch netzpolitik kenne ich nicht aber es gibt.
Wohl sogenannte blacklist in unternehmen die unter anderem auch logbuch netzpolitik sperren ein aufruf der domain logbuch netzpolitik de ist somit oft gar nicht möglich
was da genau dahinter steckt
böse böse verdächtige domain oder allgemeine einstellung der sekt weiß ich auch nicht werde ich aber bei gelegenheit mal nachfragen ihr bedient nun mal nicht
die mainstream kanäle und das ist auch gut so wie ich finde dann ist es aber auch nur logisch dass die reichweite medial etwas begrenzter ist aber ihr bleibt so authentisch seriös und eurer policy treu,
und sonst welche zur monetarisieren braucht wollt ihr nicht und ihr hoffe ihr packt das auch so da war jetzt viel.
Moderne sprache drin ich glaube das waren lob.
Ja
Ja gesperrt sind wir.
Ja ist tatsächlich so ich habe.
Bösen open source community.
Ja ich habe nämlich von ich das.
Komm gerade hier in meiner e-mail suche nicht an die nachricht aber mich hatte auch ein höherer darauf hingewiesen dass man wenn man beim pinhole also diesem.
Tracker blogger also ist ein das paypal ist ein
fürs raspberry pi ursprünglich mal konzipierte aber genauso gut im trainer auf jedem anderen server einsetzbarer angenehmer dna server bei dem man block listen einpflegen kann.
Und.
Jetzt ist es so dass in diesen standard block listen gibt es eine das ist die tracker liste von rtl oder so ist französisch franzose oder französin.
Ja und auf jeden fall in der in der,
tracker blogger liste von befindet sich die domain logbuch de so jetzt brauchst du natürlich nicht zu erwarten dass leute die block listen rausgeben besonders.
Schnell darauf antworten wenn man sich bei denen beschwert das ist klar weil so ungefähr jeder der auf dieser liste steht sich im zweifelsfall da beschwert.
Und sagt er wie hallo wir sind doch wir sind google wir sind doch keine tracker das ist natürlich verständlich gleichzeitig sollte man natürlich diesen leuten auch eine,
grobe sorgfalt
unterstellen wenn sie schon irgendwelche domains deren sprache sie noch nicht einmal sprechen als tracker bezeichnen insofern
habe ich eine e-mail geschrieben und einer e-mail adresse wo schon vorher am kontaktformular dran steht wir werfen alles weg was da hingeht ich habe mich auch in forum gemeldet und
nun.
Leider habe ich bisher keine reaktion erhalten und ich werde das mal so verlinken wo man sich da beschweren kann wer.
Also block listen geschädigte ist ist herzlich eingeladen da die quality service einmal zu bemängeln.
Ist aber das ganze ganz interessante meter frage hier nämlich auch ne wer eigentlich kontrolle über solche listen,
hat und welche beschwerde wege es gibt und wie man sozusagen die kontrolleure kontrollieren kann
meine das hat mir ja nun bei der ganzen plattform diskussion auch mehrfach und muss sagen es ist also
mindestens im selben maße kafka davor zu gehen also überhaupt erstmal einen ort zu finden wo man überhaupt sowas einkippen kann ich kann mich auch das steht da schon ewig drin und ich habe auch glaube ich vor zwei jahren schon mal,
auch da erstmal stunden damit verbracht dieses forum zu finden und irgendwo was hingeschrieben kam wo das jetzt rein versenkt wurde hat aber natürlich überhaupt nichts gebracht also wenn ihr da
in irgendeiner form bewandert seid und motiviert natürlich auch dann könnt ihr ja mal gucken was so geht.
Ansonsten kann man vermüllt vermutlich können wir uns mal darüber gedanken machen.
Irgendwelche wege der umgehung mal zu ermöglichen andere domain oder ich glaube es gibt auch ein hinten service unter dem wir erreichbar sind.
Aber gerade in euren firmen werden die sicherlich auch tor zugänge sperren und naja die liste rauszunehmen.
Empfiehlt sich übrigens sagt dass auch der betreiber von firewall dem glaube ich.
Häufigsten genutzten mirror solcher listen.
Der inzwischen diese liste mit einem kreuz versehen hat unter und das bedeutet empfehlungen nicht also die empfehlung dagegen diese liste zu nutzen.
Genau die wir hiermit auch unterstreichen weil so geht's ja nicht so geht es ja nicht.
Also ich werde noch eine sache kurz nach werfen
wenn ihr solche sachen feststellt liebe hörerinnen und hörer dass es irgendwelche sperrungen gibt oder so ich freue mich immer wenn ihr uns das meldet und dem kurz auf den grund geht dass wir wenigstens versuchen können da.
Die möglichkeit der revision irgendwie zu erreichen.
Gut kommen wir wieder zurück zur hygiene
david zwei schreibt uns heyo danke für die immer wieder guten podcast die ich immer wieder ganz oben in meiner
einsortieren sobald sie rauskommen ich habe eine ergänzung zu den hirnverbrannt hippies und korona vollpfosten das heißt jetzt,
provisionen glaube ich bei minute fünfunddreißig das problem ist glaube ich ernster als es auf den ersten blick
aussieht hier geht es ja im kern um dissonanz im öffentlichen diskurs menschen kommen trotz gleicher datengrundlage zu unterschiedlichen rückschlüsse über die welt sie auch klimawandel tempolimit etcetera p
der in der forschung dominierende erklärung ansatz für solche verhalten ist motivated riesending.
Zielgerichtetes interpretieren der datengrundlage so ein ziel kann gruppenzugehörigkeit sein es kann für eine republikanerin rational sein den klimawandel zu leugnen wenn das bedeutet dass sie ihren freundeskreis behält,
und es war für den chemie giganten dupont rational die zonen loch krise klein zu reden weil sie mit den verursachenden fc k w gutes geld verdienen,
ich denke im netz beobachten zu können dass auch die gegenwärtige dissonanz auf motivated riesending
zurückzuführen ist die menschen sind hochmotiviert aus ihren häusern zu kommen und ihre freunde zu sehen dementsprechend kann es wirklich sein dass weite teile der bevölkerung gerade deutlich empfänglich für verschwörungs-ideologen sind
quacksalber bekommen aufwand denn sie sagen was die leute hören wollen die maßnahmen sind übertrieben und müssen sofort beendet werden als das problem ist halt dass ich diese gewissheit nur mit verschwörungstheorien sind begründen lässt weil wissenschaftliche gesicherte erkenntnisse bisher schlicht keine gewissen aussagen zulassen
keine wissenschaftliche position befriedigt die motivation,
ich vermute das team recht hat wenn er mutmaß das jetzt gerade viele in die fänge von rechten spinnern geraten und sich mitreißen lassen zu den leuten die wie linus sagt,
einfach nach oben schwimmen gesellen sich wohl nicht nur spinner die bisher privat vor sich hin gesponnen haben sondern eben auch leute die bisher unpolitisch waren und dank ihrer dadurch gering medienkompetenz
ein gefundenes fressen sind klar.
Dem kann ich ja nicht nur zustimmen also das was jetzt nicht bezug auf den.
Motivated riesending wie das jetzt konkret genau definiert sind das mag sein andererseits stelle ich halt auch diese brüchige seit fest dass,
einfach leute die sich selber so als unpolitisch bezeichnen.
Was ich ein komisches wort finde ja sich da jetzt.
Auf einmal engagieren und auf einmal ideologien da zusammenpassen die vorher überhaupt nicht kompatibel miteinander zu sein schien.
Damit wären wir ja jetzt auch schon beim thema also beim nächsten thema.
Beim ersten richtigen thema.
Genau die info de.
Und zwar gibt es jetzt einen offenen brief von viro login medizinern und gesundheitsexperte innen das
die sich über die weltweite infotermin
beschweren und sagen die flutwelle an falschen und irreführenden inhalten über das corona virus ist kein isolierter ausbruch von desinformation sondern teil eines globalen,
problems die lügen sind sehr gefährlich weil sie falsche heilmittel anpreisen oder die menschen von impfungen und wirkungsvollen behandlungen,
abbringen wollen nun.
Das ist ja also falschinformation desinformationskampagnen sind ein thema dass wir hier im logbuch ja sehr regelmäßig behandeln man kann da insbesondere an die gesamten diskussionen um die,
us präsidentschaftswahlen zwanzig sechzehn zurückdenken man kann.
An verschiedene.
Ideen eines ministeriums für wahrheit zurückdenken wir haben ja auch schon in den letzten jahren diese diskussion gehabt mit den facts checker bei,
facebook die dort dann angestellt waren wir haben ja auch verschiedene möglichkeiten die jetzt gerade schon genutzt werden wenn man
auf youtube zum beispiel ein.
Beitrag über korona sieht dann gibt es da irgendwie ja sowas wie saubere informationen zu verlinkt und.
Wir sind hier an einem sehr.
Tja gefährlichen themenbereich den wir hier schon sehr lange behandeln und der jetzt hier auch nicht unbedingt anders.
Wird durch die pandemien aber der natürlich wieder ein komplett anderen.
Ein komplett anderes ausmaß an problematik jetzt hat wenn
so eine irgendwelche verschwörungstheorien über nein eleven verlieren dann einfach irgendwann
an unmittelbarer gesellschaftlicher relevanz die truva die gibt's auch heute noch die diskutieren das auch heute noch und gucken irgendwelche filme mit
aus dem zusammenhang gerissen in zusammenhängen aber die haben,
versammeln sich inzwischen nicht mehr zum thema nein eleven am berliner alexanderplatz die brauchen natürlich auch.
Neue themen jetzt ist es quasi.
Schwierig hier in diesem news flow einzugreifen wenn wie es ja hier von den medizinerinnen gefordert wird die also sagen ergreift jetzt.
Werden also aktive maßnahmen greift wertend in den news flow ein um diesen.
Der verbreitung dieser informationen entgegenzuwirken und es ist sehr.
Ein sehr schmaler grad auf dem man sich da bewegt und zwar aus aus vielen verschiedenen gründen a.
Wäre das irgendwie dass das aktive eingreifen in sagen wir mal die meinungsfreiheit anderer denn.
Revier wird sich erinnern in diesem verschwörungs-ideologen werden ja größtenteils meinungen gepaart mit,
falschinformationen oder nicht informationen also die die information gibt's nicht ich habe trotzdem die meinung dass was weiß ich bin und milena gates folgendes,
vorhaben ein anderes problem ist aber dass ich schätze.
Dass die in anführungszeichen neutralen algorithmen der sozialen netzwerke hier.
Zu dieser verbreitung massiv beitragen ja wir haben das hier auch schon sehr häufig besprochen.
Das geschäftsmodell der sozialen netzwerke ich nehme das jetzt ich nehme jetzt was was ich facebook und google youtube als die großen falsch verbreitung netzwerke aber sicherlich auch twitter.
Deren geschäftsmodell ist daten über die nutzerinnen und nutzer zu sammeln um diesen nutzerinnen und nutzer n,
werbung anzuzeigen und dieses geschäftsmodell funktioniert am besten wenn die leute auf der seite sind das heißt das primärziel,
von twitter ist
dass du weiter auf dieser seite bleibst das primärziel von facebook ist dass du weiter auf dieser seite bleibt das primärziel von youtube ist dass du weiter auf dieser seite bleibst und das funktioniert eben nur
wenn es ein stetig ansteigenden spannungsbogen gibt.
Wenn wir bei netflix eine serie gucken und die wird auf einmal langweilig dann gucken wir die nicht weiter deswegen muss also die nächste folge oder das ende der folge
eine hohe motivation haben dass wir weiter schauen im falle eines youtube-videos ist das also.
Das klassische wenn du dir jetzt fünf videos über ferraris angeschaut hast dann müssen halt jetzt noch schnellere autos kommen wenn du dir irgendwas zu autounfällen angeschaut hast dann müssen halt jetzt noch krasser kommen also es muss einfach immer,
krasser werden und die werden dir das video zeigen bei dem sie davon ausgehen,
das ist die höchste wahrscheinlichkeit hat dass du dranbleibst ja und so stellen die dir.
Neutral ja man könnte argumentieren relativ nach einem relativ neutral kriterium mit welchem video stelle ich am meisten sicher dass der linus weiter guckt.
Ein empfehlungsprogramm zusammen und das geht eben immer dann schief wenn hier.
Unwahrheiten im spiel sind die von der.
Hohen brisant sind für das verhalten der menschen oder wenn man wenn andere gezielt darauf hinarbeiten.
Mit diesen algorithmen zu spielen ja und interessanterweise macht das ja
jede youtuberin inzwischen auch ja bitte bitte like subscribe scheer lasst uns einen kommentar da dieses engagement ist ja das was die
immer haben wollen ja den ist weil das eben für youtube signalisiert dieser inhalt ist,
auf eine weise engagieren ja der macht was mit unseren nutzerinnen die gucken das und dann.
Sind sie so emotional dass die sogar einen kommentar schreiben das ist ein gutes video.
Da suchen wir uns dass das empfehlen wir mal anderen leuten gucken ob die auch einen kommentar schreibt.
Oder die glocke.
Glocke ist auch glocke ist total wichtig ich merke das jetzt als als ich will jetzt hier neu im business.
Wie ist denn so eigentlich als youtuber läuft.
Eins auf der straße am laufenden band erkannt und so na die ersten ich habe jetzt hier also ich habe einen vertrag jetzt unterschrieben welche schuhe ich beim youtuben trage.
Also mit mir selber meine hausschuhe aber läuft aber und das wäre also wenn eine ganze.
Welt auf einmal nach dieser.
Ökonomie funktioniert dann hast du natürlich sehr skurrile effekte und das ist quasi dieser technische aspekt vor dem ja auch seit jahren gewarnt wird.
Für den wir aber irgendwie kein sauberes allheilmittel gefunden haben und wo wir bei jedem mal neu darüber diskutieren müssen.
Und dann trifft das glaube ich in dieser in dieser zeit der pandemien eben auf diese tja die.
Menschen sind mit im prinzip traumatisierenden veränderungen konfrontiert ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass jetzt alle eine posttraumatische belastungsstörung haben aber es ist eine ganz plötzliche.
Ganz plötzlich auftretende situation von ungewissheit bedrohung und potenzieller unsicherheit ja das würde ich jetzt mal.
Einfach dafür würde ich mal den begriff traumatisierende nehmen ungeachtet dass es im zweifelsfall.
Ein übertriebener begriff ist ja aber es ist du hast auf einmal eine ganze menge unsicherheit in der welt du hast eine ganze menge bedrohungen in der welt ne du hast auch sich überschlagen die ereignisse den einen tag wird gesagt.
Das ist nur eine grippe nächsten tag wird gesagt wir haben alles unter kontrolle und dann solltest du dir auf einmal eine u v einführen um dich von innen zu desinfizieren ja das ist schwer vorhersehbar.
Das ist schwer vorher sichtbar.
Und irgendwann keimt ja dann auch der zweifel ja ob das wird der so eine gute idee ist.
Doch lieber gleich desinfektionsmittel trinken spritzen.
Spritzen spritze tim nicht trinken steht ja extra drauf dass man das nicht trinken soll.
Ja das hätte uns schon immer warnen müssen dass dass man das da drauf schreiben muss.
Und die leute dann hast du wir haben es ja auch hier ein eingangs gehört und das ist glaube ich übrigens aber das bemängelt ich auch immer wieder und hat ich denke.
Das ist zu einem der ganz fürchterlichen versäumnisse der medienkompetenz in unserem land gehört das.
Die grundzüge wissenschaftlichen denkens also der erkenntnistheorien.
Eigentlich nur ein sehr kleiner teil der bevölkerung mitgeteilt werden ich habe ein abitur gemacht ohne dass mir sinnvoll mal erklärt wurde wie.
Was es bedeutet dinge zu wissen was es bedeutet dinge prüfen zu müssen und so also ich habe einen,
in physik gemacht ja das war also da wurden natürlich naturgesetze betont und wie man sie erfasst aber so ich
glaube dass ich tatsächlich erst im späteren verlauf so richtig gelernt habe alles klar das sind das ist,
faktisch das ist das ist objektiv dann gibt es meine und dann gibt es interpretation die fakten die wir kennen lassen aber von mir aus auch unterschiedliche interpretationen und spielräume
zu und der spiel besteht jetzt nun mal darin zu erkennen was.
Zulässige interpretation der realität sind und was nicht und dann geht es in ein ganz wilden raum wo.
Leute nur einen teil davon verstanden haben nur ein teil die zum beispiel gehört haben glaubt nicht immer alles was man euch sagt sondern prüft das mal.
Ja und die das dann für ein total klugen spruch halten
und in ihren videos auf youtube die ganze zeit sagen leute glaubt nicht alles was ihr lest sucht mal selber im internet die quellen sind alle im internet da steht das drin ja und ich glaube dass das.
Wirklich also ich bin da auch persönlich ein bisschen verzweifelt wenn ich dann hier solche youtube-videos mir mal mit der kneifzange auf zwei meter entfernung angucke was für ein,
ziemlich offensichtlicher quatsch dort mit einer.
Und ich bin da immer frag mich immer ob das einfach nur eine manie ist in der da ein paar worte aneinandergereiht werden oder ob das wirklich kunstvoll klug ausgewählte.
Versatzstück es immer so vertrauen schaffen jedenfalls ist es nicht schwierig.
Diese behauptungen zum beispiel eines kenne jason zu prüfen,
und zu widerlegen das ist nicht schwierig das einfach nur zeitaufwendig und der typ redet halt wie ein wasserfall das heißt während der sich einfach am laufenden band irgendwelchen quatsch ausdenkt,
musst du jeden einzelnen dieser quatsch versatzstück hinterher recherchieren und sie widerlegen was jemand getan hat.
Und zwar wurde das veröffentlicht auf tv online de online ist ein von,
steuerbetrug des nachrichtenportal und da hat sich der journalist jonas müller töven die arbeit gemacht am achten mai zweiundzwanzig uhr veröffentlicht also hier am.
Feiertag ja und hat sich einfach mal angeschaut was behauptet dieser caps.
Ist das richtig oder ist es nicht richtig ja und.
Eine eine andere herangehensweise die ich tatsächlich einfach nicht unerwähnt lassen kann hat der.
Sei mal den verschwörungstheorien nicht abgeneigt hat sicherheitsexperte,
sich angeschaut nicht abgeneigt heißt er behandelt sie sehr gerne ja und guckt sich das sehr gerne an ich denke ist aber selber keiner und zwar heißt der felix von leitner der beträgt betreibt so ein kleines blog
und da schreibt er am neunten mai als quarantäne unterhaltung empfehle ich übrigens die verschwörungstheorien in kombination zu betrachten,
dann kommt nämlich raus dass bill gates der dämlichste kriminelle aller zeiten ist sowas wie eine kombination aus den panzerknacker und doktor evelyn.
Bill gates will also die weltbevölkerung dezimieren deren windows und office käufe die hälfte seines vermögens haus machen.
Dafür kauft er in einem chinesischen biowaffen labor das schlechteste virus das sie haben.
Experten sagen dass virus ist ungefährlicher als die saisonale grippe.
Ich würde ja ein joke machen aber willy hat von irgendwie immer zuverlässige funktionierende produkte gekauft.
Mit diesem schlechten virus fährt er da die weltwirtschaft runter von der die andere hälfte seines vermögens kommt.
Aber keine sorge geht's hat einen trumpf im ärmel er kauft über öffentliche deklarierte spenden zehn prozent einfluss in der who der behörde mit den wenigsten befugnissen weltweit,
bedenkt dass begabtes über windows und office praktisch alle behörden der welt hätte erpressen oder kontrollieren können,
und warum macht er das damit er die bevölkerung micro schicken kann,
gut der profit davon flüsse nach china denn will gates besitzt gar keine mikrochip fertigung
und die dabei herauskommenden daten werden auch nicht mehr sehr viel wert denn ihr lauft ja eh schon alle mit pilsenern in der tasche rum und die bewegung von mittellose obdachlosen in der dritten welt sind jetzt nicht unbedingt aktienmarkt gold.
Ok ok warte er macht das nicht nur wegen der mikrochips er macht das um an den impfstoffen zu verdienen.
Klar er verbrennt also so etwas wie fünfzig milliarden us-dollar für einen erwarteten
für ein zu erwartenden erlös von fünf milliarden es erinnert mich an alten an einen alten spruch von costa lani es ist sehr leicht an der börse millionär zu werden du musst bloß
als milliardär anfangen,
und ich finde das tatsächlich also wann gut man kann jetzt auch nur bei felsblock meinen ganzen artikel vorlesen weil die ja immer sehr kurz sind aber das,
ich finde es ist einfach mal sehr schön zeigt dass häufig diese verschwörungstheorien auch schon ein.
Im inneren gefüge ihre argumentation nicht unbedingt stichhaltig sind oder wie siehst du das tim.
Also mich verwirrt das alles nach wie vor und ich unterstütze eine eine petition die hier veröffentlicht wurde auf erwarb punkt org,
corona impfstoff nur mikrochips von apple da heißt es bis,
geld will bekanntlich die ganze menschheit schippen lassen die zwangsimpfung soll dabei durch zwangsimpfung herbeigeführt werden und die zu überwachung zum zweck des transmann durch fünf dafür investiert biggles milliarden und beeinflusst mit seinen beziehungen zu reptiloiden wissenschaftlern alle regierungen der welt
oberhalb und unterhalb der erde aufgrund seiner microsoft vergangenheit ist aber klar dass die chips sicher von microsoft hergestellt und höchstwahrscheinlich mit windows betrieben werden dieses system ist aber leider sehr
für seine fehleranfällig bekannt,
bestätigen fast alle computerexperten in den sozialen netzwerken deswegen fordern wir ein impft chip von apple die bundesregierung muss apple bei der entwicklung eines impfcheck unterstützen
der uns die gewohnte qualität unter die haut implantiert wir wollen keinen chip in uns der laufend abstürzt oder aufgrund von.
Anderen parasiten falsche informationen an die geheimdienste sendet wir wollen ein einfaches und stylisches betriebssystem geimpft bekommen mit dem wir unkompliziert unsere apple-geräte synchronisieren können deswegen gibt gar keine chance jagt ja zu apple.
Super ja.
Die sache sortiert sich von alleine ganz klar ach ja man muss.
Es ist es ist leider.
Das ist wirklich krass.
Ich glaube tatsächlich also.
Wir müssen natürlich auch aufpassen und das ist auch so teil der debatte dass wir jetzt sozusagen diesen wahnsinn,
nicht ob seines wahnsinns auch zu sehr unter die lupe halten ja klar da gibt's so ein paar wörte leute und ehrlich gesagt ich finde es befremdlich dass das überhaupt so viel.
Raum bekommt in der betrachtung,
ja okay stehen paar handels- irgendwie produzieren klar in stuttgart sind jetzt irgendwie schon sehr viele leute zusammengekommen ja auf einmal waren das keine ahnung was da die schätzung waren zwei dreitausend,
definitiv zu viel vielleicht waren sie auch mehr ich weiß gar nicht auf jeden fall
freue ich mich natürlich so ja okay und warum kommen sie dahin so weil es eben auch schon wieder so ein verstärkung faktor ist und damit arbeitet natürlich diese ganze branche sage ich mal.
Dass sie alles so überspitzt macht und das haben wir auch bei donald trump im wahlkampf gesehen ja der typ hatte die ganze zeit erdheilung,
weil er einfach von allen leuten so also absurd angesehen wurde.
Ja so ah ja der macht immer so krasse sprüche und der ist ja total over the top aber der hat ja gar keine chance und während alle anderen präsidentschaftskandidaten richtig viel geld einsammeln mussten hat er diese quasi über diesen wahnsinn.
Mehr oder weniger kostenlos bekommen und so aber logbuch netzpolitik ist dieser ganze scheiß jetzt ja auch schon seit zehn minuten irgendwie ein thema das ist wirklich das absurde an der ganzen situation.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher also dass das schöne ist ja die also es ist ein.
Ein wichtiger aspekt einer empirisch fundierten theorie ist dass sie auch wieder erlebbar sein muss also sie muss bestimmte annahmen treffen die.
Würden sie eintreten eindeutig diese theorie widerlegen ja also das heißt sie darf nicht alles unser gegenteil beweisen sondern sie muss.
Sie hat die anforderungen dass ihr bestimmte sachen auch mal bestimmte pflöcke einfach mal in den boden rammen und sagt das ist so und wenn das
beweisbar nicht so ist dann stimmt meine theorie nicht mehr und bei diesen verschwörungstheoretikern die arbeiten nämlich genauso dass sie immer alles und sein gegenteil als beleg für die theorie werden.
Und ich ich meine wenn du dir diese videos anschaust ja die die arbeit nehmen mit ganz mit ganz klassischen,
es geht immer los mit dieses video wird bald gelöscht das wird hier zensiert müsste jetzt bitte bitte ladet das runter und ladet es woanders hoch damit es verbreitung findet ich bin hier schon mal ich komme aus dem untergrund dann.
Wenn irgendwo einen hinweis gegeben wurde das oder wenn irgendwo ein fakt,
unumstößlich ist der gegen die theorie spricht dann wird klar gesagt aha und das glaubt ihr jetzt ne dass ihr wohl völlig klar dass die nicht wollen dass diese theorie aufhält ne ich frag mich auch ernsthaft weißt du,
wie du dir jetzt als bill gates vorkommen muss wenn du irgendwie diesen genialen plan hast ne du hast die die die,
die who gekauft du bist jetzt bereit endlich die menschheit zu chippen siebzig jahre oder wie alt der typ ist endlich an deinem lebensziel und dann kommt ausgerechnet,
jason und ein paar vom alexanderplatz dir auf die schliche ja und,
machen wir jetzt einen strich durch die rechnung ne ich meine da hättest du dir echt ein bisschen mehr mühe geben müssen das ist wirklich.
Ja das ist auch so eine der der schönen und einfachen feststellung so wie wie wie gut kann so eine weltverschwörung sein.
Wenn sie eine hohlkörper irgendwie da ohne weiteres dahinter kommen wie wie die so läuft ne.
Aber das problem ist tatsächlich tim ich glaube also es ich kenne fälle von erwachsenen.
Grundsätzlich rational zugänglichen menschen die gerade oder auch schon seit längerem auf derartige inhalte abfahren und.
Ich auch.
Das hat also es ist sehr.
Na du kommst wenn du dann ernsthaft mal versucht mit denen zu sprechen kommst du immer an dem punkt wo die ganze wenn dann sagst du guck mal hier haben wir was vom,
vom ndr oder sowas ne das ist ja da diese tolle gekauft das sind medien also ich bitte das gucke ich mir doch nicht an oder wenn du den jetzt sagen würdest hier guck mal da gibt's einen journalisten der hat unter der sagen ja auch sofort online,
das sind die mit dem hast du das.
Ja ich lache aus verzweiflung.
Das ist natürlich recht wobei man an der stelle mal kurz falls es jemand nicht weiß also online ist irgendwann mal war so dass.
Für die telekom betriebene nachrichtenportal weil sie der meinung war guter internetzugang brauchen so nachrichtenportal dann haben sie festgestellt dass nicht mehr brauchen und dann hat sich quasi online
als nachrichtenmagazin daraus gekauft aber die domain behalten und deswegen.
Genau ströme betreibt das.
Genau deswegen laufen die immer noch mit diesem produkt namen der telekom durch die gegend und ich halte das auch nach wie vor für keine gute idee aber ist halt so da hat auf jeden fall nichts mit zu tun hat sich schon bei drei raus gekoppelt.
Sagst du sagst du guck mal im internet.
Ja da gibt's auch andere meinungen.
Google doch mal tee und fünf.
Oh mann ja das ist du hast doch recht und das ist es ist,
es ist es schwierig und ich verstehe auch oder oder kann
ansatzweise nachvollziehen wie so leuten gehen muss wo es mehr so als einer im bekanntenkreis ist der da so breit geht sondern wurde unter umständen so 'ne ganze community hast von leuten die halt so
ich bin ja unpolitisch so aber was ich da jetzt gehört habe das ja ganz schlimm so ne und ich merke das auch immer wieder bei meinen diskussionen mit,
weiß ich war so sachen wieso homöopathie was jetzt so vielleicht erstmal so auf den ersten blick,
vielleicht nichts damit zu tun hat meiner meinung nach hause schon eine menge dann irgendwann so immer dieses ding kommt so ja man kann ja auch nicht alles erklären uns gibt es kann ja auch es kann ja auch dinge geben die
ja du kannst dir das bloß nicht vorstellen dass das irgendwie möglich ist und wo wo dann alle auch jede logik und jede beweisführung jede wissenschaftliche methode
einfach auch absurde umgelegt wird wo du tausend mal sagen kannst so ja nee es gibt aber keine einzige studie die es beweist so.
Es muss ja nicht immer alles darüber laufen sondern was ich glaube,
dann auch so bei glauben ist dann irgendwie wichtiger und mittlerweile haben wir ja sogar bischöfe und kirchen sonstige kirchenvertreter die.
Ja die ja sonst immer bastion der rationalität und des also ich meine das jetzt überhaupt nicht überraschend.
Verstehe ich überhaupt nicht wie wie wie jemand sich jetzt wundert leute die glauben dass ihre sünden vergeben vergeben wurden weil irgendwo in jerusalem einer ans kreuz geschlagen worden sein soll
dass die jetzt auch irgendwie bei in korona zeiten verschiedene abwege theorien entfalten halte ich jetzt nicht für so unwahrscheinlich.
Hat den wahrscheinlich der heilige geist ein geflüstert.
Ja naja so also vielleicht haben sie einfach auch das gefühl dass sie in diesem allgemeinen glaubenswert bewerb jetzt zurückliegen ja,
wie die leute glauben nicht mehr unseren scheiß sondern den scheiß da müssen wir aber jetzt mal schnell nachliefern.
Wir sind die sich denn jetzt an und denken sie es alter den scheiß glauben die leute und unsere sorgfältig gepflegte brauchtümer ja sorgfältig die gut ausgedachte geschichte stichhaltig ja,
bis jetzt auf die sache mit der jungfrau aber das glauben die und uns glauben die auf einmal nicht mehr ja klar kann sein dass sie da.
Die fürchten jetzt auf einmal den gates mehr als als das fegefeuer da da bricht das ganze businessmodel zusammen.
Aber also ich denke der der der der die parallelität zur zur religion ist wahrscheinlich tatsächlich auch eine unterschätzte weil es sind ja,
tatsächlich die bereiche in denen sich verschwörungstheorien.
Entwickeln ja wenn man mal so schaut worüber gibt es denn verschwörungstheorien über das wirtschaftssystem.
Über irgendwelche sachen nach dem leben und über große historische ereignisse.
Das sind die dinger um die sich verschwörungstheorien ranken beispielsweise irgendein paar amerikaner steigen in der rakete landen auf dem mond kann nicht sein.
Kann nicht sein oder ein paar.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht aus welchem land mohammed tatsächlich dann kam aber es eigentlich auch unerheblich fliegen los und landen im world trade center,
wie konnte das passieren das muss doch jemand gewusst haben und da entstehen dann bei den großen historischen ereignissen die keinen sinn machen.
Weil sie das bisher geglaubt e in frage stellen ja,
übrigens wie die japaner können bis nach amerika fliegen und dann eine basis angreifen wir haben gedacht das geht nicht zack verschwörungstheorie und.
In genau diesem phänomenbereich decken ja auch die religionen ab.
Wie ich werde älter wie oma klappt auf einmal um ist tot der kann doch gar nicht sein ich muss weiterleben wo die muss ihr woanders weiterleben da wo ich nicht hin kann sonst hätte ich sie ja schon gefunden also ist die wahrscheinlich im himmel,
und die ist wahrscheinlich gestorben weil wir gestern nicht genug essen verbrannt haben.
Weil wir selber gegessen haben weil wir gierige menschen sind und dann nicht hier unserem goldenen kalb gegeben haben oder so ne also.
Es ist es ist schon so dass die gehirne des menschen als sinnsuche maschinen angelegt sind und eben hippotherapie,
bauen und versuchen diese zu prüfen dummerweise in der regel durch bestätigung und nicht durch widerlegen das ist ja das was der mensch schwer
lernen musste das wahres wissen sich nicht erlangen lässt durch das bestätigen von hypothesen sondern durch das widerlegen von hypothesen
was ich gerade schon sagte eine theorie muss annahmen treffen die sich in der realität widerlegen lassen,
sei es theoretisch sei es praktisch ins deswegen ist ja auch heute noch die relativitätstheorie als theorie bekannt und ist jedes mal eine große nachricht wenn,
ein experiment die relativitätstheorie nicht widerlegt hat obwohl es dazu angelegt war sie zu widerlegen
das sind ja die die großen meldungen aus der aus der physik die uns dann noch jahrzehnte später beschäftigen ja gravitationswellen und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich fürchte dass das ein zutiefst menschliche aspekt ist und ich glaube dass das.
Aktive ein aktives verständnis in.
Erkenntnistheoretische überlegungen erfordert sich dem zu nähern und,
die dem auch entgegenzutreten ein interessantes beispiel ist ja wie will man ja.
Tatsächlich jetzt mal nicht außen vor lassen seit längerer zeit hält sicher die theorie auch von donald trump verbreitet.
Dass das nun pandemien corona virus in einem forschungslabor in wuhan entstanden ist und das forschungslabor in woran.
Bestreitet das ja das ist aber ein weltbekannter forschungslabor das corona viren forscht und zwar.
Mithilfe von fledermäusen was daran liegt dass fledermäuse halt einfach ohne ende viren tragen ja das ist also hat jetzt nichts besonderes dass du fledermäuse zur viren forschung nimmst bei korona v weil die die halt tragen wie nichts gutes und jetzt.
Das haben natürlich schon vor monaten leute herausgefunden die also irgendwie ein bisschen gegoogelt haben damals war es noch so dass einfach woher und corona virus gegoogelt dann hast du halt diese studien gefunden weil die halt von diesem labor aus wuhan kam.
Und heute morgen noch in deutschland funk- wurde das halt behandelt dass das eben
eine möglichkeit ist dass das geschehen ist ich halte das noch nicht mal vor ausgeschlossen ja das ist irgendein ganz fürchterlichen labor unfall gab
in diesem labor in wuhan das werden dann schon leute irgendwann herausfinden oder nicht aber was relativ ausgeschlossen ist ist dass das absichtlich war.
Es ist auch ausgeschlossen dass dass das daher kam also es ist halt einfach mal.
Nee das hat heute der deutschland deutschland punkt tatsächlich gesagt dass der einzige wo du sagen das ist ausgeschlossen dass es daher kam es halt eine liste der erforschten viren von den forscherinnen die in diesem labor sind und,
würden vielleicht das corona virus da nicht mit da drauf schreiben das war die heute in deutschland funke sagte aber okay.
Das ist okay dass das ein virus war was da auch durchgegangen ist meinetwegen weil das kommt ja auch irgendwoher aber die these ist ja nicht das kommt
das ist von dort aus hat von dort aus verbreitung gefunden sein die behauptung die im raum ist ist ja es wurde enginieert es wurde künstlich gebaut.
Das ist und das.
Komplett widerlegt das ist einfach das
kann man diesem virus ansehen und ja also das ja glauben heißt nicht wissen trotzdem gibt's enormen,
bedarf das zu glauben und glauben ist immer dann besonders erfolgreich wenn er auch mit so einem hals versprechen kommt und das da ist natürlich jetzt diese ganze kronaz krise ein echtes problem
weil die offizielle darstellung ist halt alles ganz furchtbar ist ganz schlimm wir müssen was tun und wir beschränken euch ein und das ist natürlich jetzt nicht gerade das heilsversprechen mit die jungfrauen erwarten dich am ende deines lebens etcetera sondern es ist halt irgendwie grimm und dem und das das,
das ist erstmal an sich nicht sexy fragt man sich natürlich okay was ist jetzt an diesen ganzen anderen geschwoben so ein hals versprechen,
eigentlich auch keins weil's ja sozusagen so 'ne ganz furchtbare welt,
die sich an allen ecken und enden gegen dich verschworen hat mit playern die von denen vorher noch gar nicht wusstest dass es sie überhaupt gibt.
Wahrscheinlich weil sie es auch nicht gibt ja und das solltest du dann irgendwie fressen was macht das eben so attraktiv und es ist halt dann doch im kern oft einfach dieses,
dieses ding dass dass die leute in so einer überforderung der komplexität der welt sind was auch,
gut nachvollziehbar ist die welt ist komplex ja und die wird von sekunde zu sekunde auch komplexer da gibt's dann halt diese leute die nennen sich wissenschaftler die quasi das verständnis und die einsicht,
sich reinschaufeln und andere leute haben die halt so nicht weil sie schlicht keine wissenschaftler.
Sind nicht sein wollen oder die fähigkeiten dazu ordentlich haben und die stehen dann irgendwie da und fühlen sich so ein bisschen naja mir kann man ja viel erzählen,
stimmt auch und den wird dann auch viel erzählt ja nur wer jetzt hier irgendwie die wahrheit hat,
das kann man ja gar nicht machen und dann kommt halt so dieses ding mit,
aber hier du bist ja erleuchtet du wachst ja dieses aufwachen du du bist ja du bist ja außerwählt,
du hast es verstanden und du gehörst du so einer kleinen gruppe im untergrund,
die bedeutung hat weil sie wird ja auch verfolgt und du siehst es ja überall,
das wertet dich auf und das ist so das heilsversprechen im kleinen dass du auf einmal eine besondere rolle hast weil du ja zu diesem erweckt
diesen auserwählten gehört zu diesen diesen diesen erleuchteten so und dann sind wir eigentlich schon wieder voll in diesem engels moment mit drin und das macht die sache einfach auch so
so schwierig so dieses es könnte ja sein dass und wenn ich da an der großen sache dran bin dann weil wenn ich es nicht bin,
dann ist alles so wieder wie vorher und das war jetzt sogar ja auch nicht.
Tja.
Können wir nur hoffen lassen an der stelle.
Wir können es an der stelle nur offen lassen und ich denke,
ich glaube das einzige was ich leuten mit auf den weg geben würde ist wann immer euch jemand sagt das könnt ihr selber nachlesen das könnt ihr selber prüfen dann tut es doch bitte auch.
Dann tut es doch bitte einfach auch könnte genauso gut also könnt ihr sehr gerne hier in unseren in unseren sendungen machen was ja auch immer wieder passiert ja wir haben ziemlich gute
hörerinnen kommentare die.
Kleinste speckte die ich falsch sage hier sofort feststellen ja zum beispiel dass ich mich mit der,
zeit der infektiöse auseinander irgendwie vertan habe ja und zack auch erwischt ich kann noch nicht mal genau sagen wie ich die vier jahre habe super danke ja wir müssen ja auch hier mit unserer reichweite,
verantwortungsbewusst umgehen und wenn euch jemand irgendetwas sagt so das und das ist so und so und das.
Eine krasse sache und es wird ihr irgendwo anders berichtet da muss ich sagen bei allem was ich über das deutsche.
Und auch die europäische und auch die amerikanische medienlandschaft weiß etwas was nicht berichtet wird.
Gibt es hier quasi nicht weil's einfach da ist dann der markt wirklich mal für uns ja das
ist jetzt nicht ein kartell aus öffentlich-rechtlichen rundfunk entscheiden kann das über eine bestimmte sache nicht berichtet wird oder so ja dafür stehen die alle in viel zu großer konkurrenz um reichweite das
sag ich mal dinge dann doch berichtet.
Werden und in jedem dieser zeitungsartikel die es so gibt ja da kann man sich insbesondere auch mit journalismus sehr auseinandersetzen wenn man sollte,
in der regel eine erkennbare trennung von fakten und interpretationen vorweisen,
jetzt kommt natürlich der aspekt hinzu dass nicht zu jeder meldung jeder kontext gegeben wird und natürlich,
je nachdem wie die stimmung grade ist das der ein oder andere fakt mal nicht berücksichtigt wird beispiel sind so tagesschau beiträge sind unglaublich cool kurz ne die müssen sehr irgendwie in minuten passen die.
Sind dazu prädestiniert das problem zu haben nicht den gesamten kontext darzustellen tagesschau beitrag über irgendeinen,
neues geschehnis im israel palästina konflikt hast zwei minuten zeit zu sagen dieses oder jenes ist passiert du kannst aber jetzt nicht den kompletten konflikt neu einordnen.
Gerade deshalb ist es ja so wichtig sich aus verschiedenen medien die seriös arbeiten zu informieren und so ist es ja auch kein zufall dass ich selbst sag ich mal zweifelhafte pseudonymen blogger,
mir durchlese umzuschauen.
Wie die denn so arbeiten aber man muss in der lage sein zu erkennen wann jemand seriös arbeitet und wann nicht und das,
ist leider glaube ich etwas was alle selber
können müssen insofern wenn euch eure youtuber schon motivieren sachen selber nachzulesen dann tut es bitte auch und sei es nur um euch nicht im freundeskreis lächerlich zu machen wenn jemand sagt wo hast du das denn her dass ihr dann sagt steht im internet,
da muss man schon gucken was sind was sind seriöse quellen und was nicht.
Und was sind seriöse quellen also anfangs schon angesprochen wir haben jetzt diese absurde situation.
Das ist jetzt druck auf große plattformen gibt die ja mit ihren algorithmen,
quasi dazu beitragen dass sich solche informationen so viral weiterverbreiten von fordern sie geradezu auf genau das zu machen was wir eigentlich gar nicht von ihnen wollten nämlich da so sensorisch einzugreifen und redaktionell
auf einmal zu arbeiten und das ist nochmal so ein problem für sich aber ein und ich hoffe dass ich diesen diese anmerkungen
später nicht mal bereuen werde aber ich denke dass derzeit kann man,
ganz gut daran ablesen dass die dinge nicht so sind wie sie von den ganzen schwung dargestellt werden,
weil es in der wikipedia anders steht und dieses alte argument die wikipedia wäre ja unzuverlässig weil kann ja jeder ändern ne,
ja hat sich ja herausgestellt dass dieses kann ja jeder erinnern gewisser hinsicht so ein bisschen dazu beigetragen hat dass es sehr viel resilienz sich verhält als eben,
youtube also meine die zahl also ich sage nicht alles ist wahr auf wikipedia das ist nicht der punkt weil du kannst in sachen die.
Überhaupt keinerlei fokus der gesellschaft haben die überhaupt
nicht irgendwie eine große bedeutung haben da kannst du natürlich immer mal wieder irgendeine kleine information in irgend so ein artikel rein implantieren dann lungert die da so ein bisschen unentdeckt rum aber das liegt dann vor allem daran dass das thema dann auch an sich erstmal so,
kein interessiert da kann was weiß ich fünf jahre lang drin stellen tim ist der geilste ja bis die welt dann irgendwann mal draufkommt so.
Solange hast du es geschafft.
Ja genau da so ja ist gleich der geilste ist meine zweite geilste klar das kommt dann halt irgendwann raus aber bei großen sachen.
Wie jetzt dieser pandemien großen ereignissen ja auch wichtigen dingen da ist dann natürlich auch so eine kollektive aufmerksamkeit dabei und da.
Da kannst du dann nicht
kontrollieren und da kannst du nicht dich irgendwie mit mit zehn millionen bei der via irgendwie fünf millionen beim zdf kriegst du da diese wikipedia berichterstattung auch nicht ungeboren und wie gesagt ne ich weiß nicht ob ich diesen kommentar nochmal bereuen würde aber.
Derzeit stellt sich mir das eben so da und am ende muss sogar youtube letzten endes derzeit vehement auch auf wikipedia verlinken,
dein flat das video da aufmachst steht ja immer gleich so ja hier verschwörungstheorie lies mal lieber in der wikipedia nach weil da.
Könnte es sogar sein dass die wahrheit steht bei uns nicht.
Ja ich würde aber generell sagen.
Ich wäre vorsichtig eine spezifische quelle als verlässliche anzugeben ich denke dass am ende entscheidend ist wie gearbeitet wird also auch sehr gutes beispiel,
bis vor kurzem hätte niemand gedacht dass risa,
eine besonders verlässliche quelle ist weil er halt musikvideos gemacht hat hat sich aber dann irgendwann mal hingesetzt und hat sich in ein thema eingefuchst und dazu fakten zusammengetragen hat er eben ein journalistisches werk
geschaffen und dieses journalistische werk war dadurch erkennbar,
dass es ja sehr spezifisch seine fakten und quellen benannt hat
ja und gesagt hat das habe ich daher das habe ich daher das funktioniert auf youtube ein bisschen besser als es bei uns hier im podcast funktioniert wir haben aber auch zu jedem thema immer unsere links sammlung wo im zweifelsfall alle unsere quellen,
auf die wir uns beziehen drin verlinkt sind ja kann ausnahmen bestätigen die regel über hinweise freue ich mich dann aber.
Ich denke das ist das was am ende stattfinden muss ist eine prüfung jedes einzelnen werkes auf aha ist das jetzt irgendwie.
Wurde hier ordentlich gearbeitet oder nicht und dann gibt's natürlich in der zweiten ebene so etwas wie,
was weiß ich bei der oder jener der publikation die haben einen haben jetzt nicht bestehen nicht im ruf regelmäßig unsauber gearbeitet zu haben ja gibt's ja in deutschland dann auch gibt es einige wo man weiß
da bist du sehr vorsichtig gibt andere wo du weißt dass jetzt schon alles grob immerhin hauen was die schreiben
beziehungsweise die gehen dann auch ehrlich damit um wenn es mal nicht der fall ist
zum beispiel diese relotius affäre wo man einfach mal ich meine für den scheiß den der relotius im spiegel geschrieben hat da gibt's eine ganze reihe
an publikationen die da nicht so ein gewese drum gemacht hätten wenn einer ihrer autoren,
mal den ein oder anderen misst sich ausdenkt weil die potenziell daraus funktionieren dass die sich einfach nur mist ausdenken.
Ok dann haben wir noch ein kleines kleinen ausflug zu den korona apps denn wie wir immer.
Beschreiben gehen die korona app diskussion auf und ab vor allem in ihrer qualität und in der kompetenz der an der diskussion teilnehmenden aber natürlich auch im gezerre der.
Auseinandersetzungen mit diesem mittel der app als solches ja es gibt immer noch eine ganze reihe leute die.
Heilsversprechen damit verbinden und nicht ja nicht sauber einsortieren können wo stärken und grenzen dieses einsatzes sind und es gibt.
Natürlich immer noch menschen die ja starke.
Möglichkeiten suchen dass irgendwie zu umzusetzen und da hat sich jetzt.
Kleine anmerkung noch bevor wir darauf eingehen also.
Es gibt mittlerweile so viele vorstellungen davon was eine korona app ist ja dass man hier vielleicht generell von corona apps als sammelsurium unterschiedlicher vorstellungen worum sich so eine app kümmern könnte gelten.
Ist es quarantäne ist es gesundheitsmesse ist es dressing etcetera deswegen sollte man an der stelle genau sein.
Das jetzt vor allem erstmal um diese.
Hier ist die rede von einer contact tracing.
Genau dass wir von dressing reden jetzt.
Ja und die haben sie jetzt achsel voss gefragt axel voss ist natürlich.
Hörerinnen von logbuch netzpolitik bekannt als jemand der,
schon öfter sich in diskussionen eingebracht hat ohne jetzt das thema hilfe durchdrungen zu haben aber vor allem ein freund der harten lösungen der hat jetzt hier den das argument eingebracht.
Also die apps contact racing app soll auf jeden fall freiwillig sein.
Sagt er so spezifisch das geht nur freiwillig wir brauchen aber mindestens sechzig prozent nutzer damit das großflächig funktioniert und man neue infektionen da schnell erkennt damit bezieht er sich auf designstudie die von allen zitiert wird
und jetzt sagt er naja
wenn man schon etwas freiwillig macht dann müsste man sich überlegen ob man nicht anreize schafft zum beispiel im grenznahen bereich nutzer wieder reisen.
Zu lassen wer eine solche app habt sollte auch zuerst wieder ins restaurant kino theater oder ins freibad.
Schöne reisepläne haben sie da wäre doch schade wenn denn was passieren würde.
Und jetzt ist das also ich meine das ist halt echt ein wirklichen kompliziertes ding denn.
Bei bestimmten orten also freibad ist hier völliger quatsch ne aber bei bestem.
Arten von veranstaltung kann das ja könnte man ja durchaus sagen dass es sehr sinnvoll wäre wenn man eine möglichkeit der kontakt nach verfolgung hat ja es war zum beispiel so zu beginn der.
Dieser ganzen auseinandersetzungen als flüge noch geflogen sind war ich auf einem flug und ich musste nachher auch so eine meldung ans gesundheitsamt ausfüllen von der airline dass ich in diesem flug war.
Und das ziel dieser maßnahme war er sei es ein blatt papier das ziel dieser maßnahme war würde eine dieser personen auf diesem flug später als.
Also als als infektiös getestet oder als infiziert bestimmt werden dann würde ich darüber informiert werden können,
oder wer wäre ich darüber informiert worden hat natürlich ein bisschen damit zu tun in flugzeugen ist der luftaustausch sehr hoch da ist quasi die ganze zeit luftbewegungen drin sodass.
Jetzt die theorie habe dass dort ein.
So ein korona virus im zweifelsfall sehr viel weitere distanzen zurücklegen kann gleichzeitig vielleicht auch schneller wieder weg ist ja.
Aber sie haben einfach mal gesagt okay die sitzen längere zeit in einem offenbar geschlossenen raum eng beieinander.
Erfassen wir das mal ist aber natürlich noch ein etwas anderer schritt als zu sagen du brauchst jetzt ein handy und du musst darauf eine bestimmte app installieren um in dieses theater zu dürfen.
Zumal ja wieder also.
Ich bin hier so vorsichtig mit weil es immer wenn etwas nicht.
Erzwungen wird wenn etwas nur freiwillig ist genau solche aspekte kommen wie sie hier unser freund axel voss hervorbringt nämlich dass es ein de facto zwang gibt.
Sie,
du bist in deutschland nicht verpflichtet ein auto zu haben aber in großen teilen des landes zu wohnen bleibt dir einfach überhaupt nichts anderes übrig es ist nicht so als könntest du am gesellschaftlichen leben teilnehmen wenn du irgendwo ländlich wohnst
wenn du nicht im besitz eines fahrzeuges bist was heißt nicht dass du ein auto zwang hast aber de facto hast du einen.
Und das sind immer sehr problematische.
Pfade die da begangen werden und man sieht ja sehr klar dass der was der im schilde führt wenn er sagt es geht nur freiwillig aber deswegen müssen wir es müssen wir die leute die es nicht freiwillig machen mit so vielen nachteilen belegen.
Oder die anderen mit vorteil.
Was ja nichts anderes ist ja wenn du wenn du das heißt ohne die app darfst du nicht ins theater dass du nicht in den.
Darfst du nicht ins freibad darfst du nicht da und da hin aber die app ist freiwillig du kannst ja auch freiwillig einfach nicht ins kino gehen das ist natürlich eine pervertierung dieses gedankens der freiwilligkeit.
Absolut also ich meine was woran es natürlich hier schon mal generell krank ist in dem moment wo du in irgendeiner form sagst mit app geht's dir besser als ohne heißes jahr es gibt so eine art smartphone besitz,
mobilfunkvertrag abschluss zwang.
Fünf phone.
Ja genau ne mit chip und das dürfte sich rechtlich schon sehr schwer.
Machen lassen oder stellt jetzt die bundesregierung einem dann im zweifelsfall wenn man kann es hat auch telefon und einen entsprechenden vertrag,
kann ja durchaus sein dass also ich weiß auch dass zumindest leute gab die an so ideen gearbeitet haben wie so ein telefonliste,
hardware die weiß was quasi an diesen ganzen bluetooth austausch und so weiter an diesem ganzen dressing spaß
mitmachen kann ohne jetzt so ein richtiges telefon zu sein das hat sich dann wieder schwierig mit dem zugriff auf die daten etcetera und.
Zweifel auch noch daran dass das kommt aber das wäre ja dann in gewisser hinsicht auch noch die voraussetzung dass man sowas überhaupt umsetzen kann,
also das ist schwierig ich denke ein incentive zu bieten ja bitte aber das kann man dann sicherlich auch anders lösen
und dann muss er dann halt vielleicht sagen naja kneipen kinos,
flugzeuge bahn alles wo man längere zeit auf engeren raum mit leuten zusammenhängt öpnv alles ja haben dann an der tür ein dickes rotes einheitliches schild zu kleben wo gesagt wird
es gibt dieses racing apps benutzt die wenn wenn ihr könnt das schützt euch und andere fertig so aber nicht du kommst hier nicht rein ohne.
Genau und an den punkt kommst du ja nur über über sehr viel.
An dem punkt dass das eine kneipe sich freiwillig hinstellt und sagt okay diese app da können wir das halten wir auch für zumutbar unsere kunden dazu zu bitten das zu nutzen.
Wobei wenn man sich anschaut was die einem alles für apps empfehlen die schwelle auch relativ niedrig zu sein scheint aber.
Der weg dahin führt natürlich über eben eine maximale transparenz und am ehesten ist das so dass man,
anreize nicht durch nachteile schafft sondern anreize durch.
Durch nachteile für andere schafft die sich dies nicht machen sondern dass man mit den man kann ja zum beispiel so etwas sagen wie wir helfen dir dabei.
Du kannst da und da hin kommen wenn du auch diese app haben möchtest dann wird dir dabei geholfen die einzurichten ja oder es gibt vom,
wir machen eine schulung die dir nochmal genau erklärt wie das funktioniert damit du eine informierte entscheidung treffen kannst und sonstige dinge das sind ja alles quasi anreize ja man kann ja auch von mir aus den leuten dafür geld geben dass sie das machen ja oder.
Besser ein soziales netzwerk wo sie freiwillig ganz viele daten hochladen können aber ein es ist nicht nicht alles was für andere sofort eine diskriminierung ist ist ein anreiz und deswegen erfüllt.
Denke ich die beispiele die er hier anführt nicht die definition von schaffung eines anreize zu.
Also von mir keine ahnung also ich ich bin jetzt mal rum anreiz wäre eben du kriegst weniger du kriegst irgendwie geld dafür oder du kriegst irgendwo steuervorteil oder sonst was dass das wären.
Fünf euro weniger auf dein telekom vertrag pro monat.
Das wäre ein anreiz ja das also das wäre fünf euro rabatt
ja die die du ohne die du sonst bezahlt hättest
ja und nicht etwas wie ein preis den andere jetzt zahlen müssen den sie vorher nicht gezahlt haben also ich denke es ist sehr schwierig und da werden wir noch sehr viele debatten darüber führen und ich will jetzt,
wahrscheinlich werden wir auch in den kommentaren leute haben die sagen diese fünf euro rabatt auf den telekom vertrag sind ein problem und ich kann mir das auch sehr gut vorstellen dass es dafür auch gute argumente gibt im moment sind wir an dem punkt.
Dass ich es nach wie vor für die sinnvollste strategie halte dass die app einfach so sauber gebaut ist das alles sagen kein problem installiere ich mache ich mit und diejenigen die es dann nicht machen wollen eben.
Zahlenmäßig so wenige sind dass man sie sich erlauben kann.
Ja das einfach auch der soziale druck von alleine entsteht also in dem moment wo einfach klar ist das hilft und es ist sozusagen der der digitale mundschutz.
Ja ich meine auch auch da gab es ja viel widerstand und man hat es in gewisser hinsicht teilweise auch jetzt nur mit der ja mit dem zwang,
geschafft aber auch das wird sich irgendwann ändern.
Also auch der abstand also auch abstand halten etcetera und so weiter das ist ja etwas was einem am anfang schwer fiel weil's nicht in unserem naturell liegt weil es nicht so ist wie wir uns normalerweise verhalten haben 'ne verhaltensanpassungen,
kommt langsam und braucht zeit und braucht vorbilder und braucht sozusagen du musst wenn du wahrnimmst dass
dass die anderen das auch tun dann ergibt sich das ist natürlich so eine installierte app nicht unbedingt etwas was du so unmittelbar wahrnimmst deswegen muss es eben sichtbarer werden deswegen war mein beispiel für nur ein beispiel ja jeder ort der sozusagen,
situation schafft die schwierig ist die aber aus anderen erwägungen mittlerweile wieder erlaubt ist ja hat.
Als vorschrift darauf hinzuweisen dass es das gibt und dass es sinnvoll ist so dass immer wenn du in so einer situation kommst.
Wie so ein hinweis auf deiner zigarettenpackungen mit soja kannst du rauchen aber es gefährlich und macht füße kaputt und herausfallen keine ahnung was nicht alles,
hält die leute jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer vom rauchen ab aber trägt eben dazu bei so sonst so eine akzeptanz und so eine botschaft mit mit rein zu
bringen und ob das dann reicht keine ahnung weiß ich nicht wenn man alles sehen es gibt ja einfach noch sehr viele fragezeichen ich bin da nach wie vor relativ optimistisch dass es gelingen kann weil es doch in der mehrheit schon einfach bei allen in der gesellschaft so ist
mit das ist einfach alles was irgendwie sinnvoll und erträglich ist einfach tun damit es einfach schnell noch erträglicher für alle wird.
Aber genau da würde ich jetzt nochmal anknüpfen lieber tim und sagen.
Dass das entscheidende ist dass es sinnvoll unerträglich ist noch ist diese app nicht fertig.
Und wenn es sinnvoll und erträglich ist dann glaube ich wiederum.
Das genau sämtliche formen von irgendwie hier verpflichtend erzwingen benachteiligungen.
Die gesamte idee wieder konterkarieren,
und deswegen werde ich da bei allem enorm vorsichtig und wenn er irgendwie so ein achsel fassmer eben situation aus dem ärmel schaukelt wo man jetzt ein de facto eine app zwang
drüber durchsetzen soll glaube ich nicht dass der irgendjemandem damit gut tut ja ich denke wir müssen immer noch unter der hypothese,
operieren wir operieren immer noch unter der über these dass diese apps einen signifikanten beitrag leisten können ja wir haben studien die das behaupten,
signifikant bedeutet für die kontrolle der pandemien auf nationaler ebene mit einfluss das bedeutet nicht.
Dass es für dich persönlich als nutzerin etwas bringt oder nicht sondern wir haben ja schon sehr häufig vorgestellt im besten fall schützt diese.
Menschen die sie gar nicht wissen das ist das beste was die überhaupt hinkriegen könnte und.
Wenn wir diese hypothese glauben dann müssen wir eine app bauen die wir freiwillig so nutzen können um sie dann auch zu prüfen und da dürfen wir,
solange wir das alles unter einer hypothese haben nicht den fehler machen das zu erzwingen und ich kann mir
ich sehe das schon kommen ja das jetzt aus jetzt durch irgendwelche app zwang und vor allem
darüber dass man ja auch noch gechippt werden muss wenn man die app haben wir haben ja noch gar nicht geredet aber wenn sich das alles
jetzt so weiter diskutiert dann hast du am ende zwanzig prozent leute die app nutzen keine messbaren effekte und dann stellen sich die leute hin und sagen es nutzen nicht genug leute die app
ja und dann haben wir eine diskussion die ist ungefähr so informiert wie,
wir finden nicht genug kriminelle wir brauchen mehr vorratsdatenspeicherung ohne evidenz dafür zu haben dass die vorratsdatenspeicherung hilft fälle aufzuklären und.
Genau solche diskussionen muss man vermeiden deswegen muss jetzt erstmal eine feinst säuberlich app gebaut werden die am ende.
Alle privacy experte die sich anschauen überzeugt zu sagen hier habe ich jetzt keinen unmittelbaren einwand das ding einzusetzen,
das ist erstmal ein dickes brett was gebohrt werden muss und dann kann ich mir vorstellen dass man auch ziemlich weit kommt.
In der in der verbreitung dieser app und dann werden sich hoffentlich
ideen über zwänge oder benachteiligung von menschen die diese apps nicht nutzen oder nutzen können oder nutzen wollen auch er übrigt haben das wäre mir auf jeden fall der sehr viel libera ausgegangen.
So dann hatten wir heute nur ein thema die info die mir und die tracing privilegien zwei themen.
Ja man muss ja auch mal besprochen werden.
Wie geht's dir denn mit den mit sieben wochen zu hause bist du bist ja einer metaebene.
Ich bin immer in der metaebene ja also schon mehrfach erwähnt ist,
ist so eine phase die ich relativ gut wegstecken kann aber da bin ich auch privilegiert weil ich das einerseits immer schon gewohnt bin ist natürlich dann ja sagen wir mal für,
kinder zur schulkomplex steht sie wegfallende schule das ist natürlich nochmal so ein thema für sich was jetzt hier nicht aufdröseln möchte.
Und ich denke da wird sich das auch eher langfristig zeigen wie da die auswirkungen wirklich sind auch wie es dann bei anderen gelaufen ist
aber so jetzt für mich ist es ja eigentlich eher
beschwingt und so einfach mal so ein so ein so ein thema so ein themenkomplex vor die füße geworfen zu bekommen mit dem man sich neu auseinandersetzen kann und dann mache ich halt das was,
muss ich immer mache,
einfach mal drüber reden so machen wir hier mache ich bei so wer also von corona nicht genug kriegen kann soll vielleicht auch nochmal kurz eingeladen zu dem korona,
weekly wo es vor allem immer um diese interpretation der
zahlen die uns um die ohren geworfen werden geht aber eben auch doch mal diese ganze tracing app geschichte immer im detail was ich dort neues ergeben hatte
wird auch ganz wild diskutiert ist auch gut so.
Coming von daher mir wird es gerade nicht langweilig aber irgendwann würde ich dann auch ganz gerne mal wieder mein studio mit personen in betrieb nehmen das liegt natürlich jetzt auch noch in weiter ferne muss ich wahrscheinlich noch so ein sticker hier draus machen.
Peter ebene studio nur mit dressing app also sonst kommst du hier nicht rein.
Ja gut dann beende ich noch kurz logbuch freiheit wird am mittwoch den dreizehnten auch nochmal wieder erscheinen.
Auf youtube und unter logbuch minus freiheit de youtube kanal abonnenten.
Freut mich immer na glocke sternchen hast du nicht gesehen.
Interaktion interaktion interaktion.
Und ich möchte euch übrigens auch bitten das video herunterzuladen und auf anderen plattformen hochzuladen.
Wenn es bei youtube gelöscht wird ja das ist mir auch sehr wichtig ja kann ich euch ausdrücklich zu ermutigen und was möchte ich noch ah ja.
Logbuch netzpolitik kann natürlich auch empfehlen wenn man möchte wenn man das wenn man meint dass das menschen zuträglich ist aber nur netten menschen empfehlen.
Wir legen wert auf eine gepflegte hörerin schafft.
Und damit sind wir am beim dank der gilt dieses mal von meiner seite matthias marcel und axel.
Und mein dank gilt wie immer allen anderen die bundespolitik finanziell unterstützen daueraufträge einrichten oder nicht löschen und von daher sagen wir jetzt erstmal tschüss sind uns nächste woche irgendwie
hören wir uns wieder bis bald.
Tschau tschau.